Your parents arranged your marriage
is what a lot of people tell me,
but I actually
don't consider our marriage to have been arranged.
Let me explain.
Andrew and I did what is called a courtship,
and courtship is
the process of getting to know each other
with marriage and mind.
Essentially,
we focused on learning about each other
but excluding emotions as much as possible.
Emotions are not a bad thing,
and by the time we were engaged,
we were head over heels for each other.
But the focus was on our compatibility,
not our attraction to each other.
The difference I see between courtship
and arranged marriages
is that we didn't know if we would get married,
and we were totally fine with that.
Which is why we try to keep our emotions
out of the picture
and get to know each other platonically.
Good marriages, after all,
are built on strong friendship.
But if we were not compatible,
we wanted to be able to break up
without breaking each other's hearts.
Arranged marriages are usually where the parents
choose the spouses.
Sometimes the couple gets to know each other
before the wedding,
and sometimes they meet at the altar.
Well, I say that my dad found my husband for me,
which he did.
No one knew of Andrew would be my husband.
He found a suitor,
and that suitor became my husband.
There's more I could go into,
and if you're interested in learning more about
our Courtship
feel free to ask questions,
and I'll try to dive deeper into the soon.